good morning believe nation today's
message is keep going over to you John
Legend the thing is every successful
person you know has failed at what they
love to do before
I've been unsuccessful in my career
you just didn't know about it because I
wasn't famous yet and I was trying to be
famous I was trying to get a record deal
for six years and I kept getting turned
down and any successful person you know
even though it seems like everything
just happened for them it usually was
preceded by a bunch of failure or at
least a significant amount but the great
ones aren't the ones that don't fail
they're the ones that learn from their
failure and they keep going and they're
persistent in their tenacious and for me
I was trying to get a record deal for
from 98 to 2004 and got turned down by
every major left a record label
including the one I'm signed to now and
for me that means that even when you
hear no you have to keep going through
all those knows and take it to yes what
do you think for me usually if I started
project it doesn't matter how hard it is
oh it will be I will always continue to
finish it like for when I just started
my youtube channel I did the 10 days
challenge and
so many things break down the software
shut down on me a few times but I still
stayed up late and then kept going
finish my editing yeah there was just
about 10 days
when they kept going yeah she kept going
I think people give up too easily
I think people quit too soon I look at
my YouTube channels if you're talking
youtube I started it in 2008 and it
wasn't until 2000 it was until 2014 that
I had my major breakthrough so what is
that six years six years
yeah 2014 is when I had my first and a
big video that took off six years would
you keep on something for six years and
not see any major results and just keep
doing it right I think people just
expect instant results and when they
don't get it they quit and try to move
on to something else and then just move
on to something else and never stick
with anything it's a key to success I
look at successful companies look at
Harley Davidson I may get the numbers a
little off but they started I think in
1903 and they made five bikes a year
five motorcycles and then 1904 they made
another five motorcycles and then the
next year they made like seven
motorcycles and then you know two years
later they finally opened up the factory
and they made 50 motorcycles like how
long would you be willing to make five
motorcycles and five motorcycles in five
and then seven most people think that's
a feeling they quit too soon and so I
think with any goal that you have in
entrepreneurship or in life you have to
keep going it's gonna be way harder than
you thought it was it's why it's so
important that you have a deep passion
for because you're gonna quit if you're
in it just for some instant result
instant money instant gratification
you're gonna quit because it's gonna get
way way way too hard but if you have the
deep passion for and you keep going the
prize will
so the question that they today is what
is the thing that you're working on that
you have been working on for a long time
at least they're going to I love it
anyway Oh put you up I like it kept
going leave it in the comments below we
will join in the discussion I also want
to give a quick shout out to Christina
Archer Christina thank you so much for
breaking up a copy of my book your one
word I really really really appreciate
it and I hope you're enjoying the read
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you one
wish we'll see you soon no no much love
I will see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot so in today's world you
can't sleep there's no days off there's
no time to rest and just kick it so you
just keep going you know so even though
the album just came out like they got me
in the studio tonight I was in the
studio last night till 6 a.m. we got a
full day of like you know interviews and
running around New York and then we got
studio all night you just keep going and
that's how you keep your chops up but
there were times in the last five six
years I was very tempted to just say you
know what forget it this is too
difficult you're not gonna come up with
the album that you need and you're and
you're driving yourself crazy with it
and I was and I was and of course on top
of that I was getting quite a kicking
from the press so at that point in my
life with with so much going on
emotionally what she you know being
kicked about by that by the media and
the press and the industry almost
wishing that and some oast wishing that
my career was over I just was I was
almost ready to give up but part of my
motivation a very strong part of my
motivation to keep going was that I
always knew how terrible it would look
to young gay kids that were worried
about coming out not that they
necessarily see a great parallel with a
you know someone who was outed when they
were 35 but
I think it is a very it would look it
would be a horrible way to leave my
career to leave people thinking that my
sexuality took away my market because I
just knew that wasn't true and I felt a
kind of responsibility not only to
myself but to young gay people to say
look I because I was felt absolutely
sure that my market hadn't left me so I
felt it really important to say look it
is not damaging if you are if you have
ability it is not damaging to have
become their confidence to come out and
that in certain parts of life it really
doesn't matter anymore in certain
careers it really doesn't matter anymore
and I think just the success of the
record this time around and I hope it's
continued success will alleviate that
perception you know